[Musique]
déjà une cigarette
c'est tôt le matin encore une
[Musique]
et monsieur soit tu ne sais pas lire les
panneaux seraient wagon non fumeurs
[Musique]
voilà il fait tousser credo chien mais
c'est le contrôleur savent quelque chose
wagon fumant
[Musique]
il est temps que tu fasses quelque chose
oui tout bateau
[Musique]
[Rires]
les petits bateaux à tour se transforme
pompiers allez venez respirer l'air pur
de la campagne
vous en avez besoin que fait-il
ah oui des cigarettes ce pétard tagon
finnair et une cigarette
[Musique]
c'est vous qui avez fait ça ne ce soir
ne se sont pas très bien en retard ça si
je vous pardonne à ses gars merci je ne
serai plus là laissant emporter et
transformer la boîte de cigares en plus
tard attention par soeur petit bois
doubs et au revoir et merci
[Musique]
on